hey guys it is the 12th of November
today my name is Jess and you're
watching games bunnies if you want the
best technical experience around so call
of duty black ops 3 digital foundry
reckons you should pick up the ps4
version digital foundry compared how
well each console performed during the
game's campaign and found that in
cutscenes both the ps4 and xbox one
could achieve 1080p although the actual
native resolution during gameplay is
targeted to be 1080p on ps4 but just 900
p on xbox one Sara Board found that the
ps4 edition drops momentarily to 13 60 x
1080 before achieving full 1080p at 1920
x 1080 and there was some blur across
distant details comparatively they
claimed that the xbox one edition can
rarely hold it 1600 x 900 target only
reaching a sustained 1280 x 900 res even
in less stressful game to make things
digital foundry have reported that black
ops 3 on xbox one is a significant
technical downgrade from the performance
of advanced warfare last year both
consoles also had trouble maintaining 60
frames per second particularly in more
intense areas web performance drops to
around 40 to 55 FPS any Nintendo Direct
presentation happened today and here's
the cool stuff that came out of that
earlier this year Nintendo asked who
fans wanted to see arrive next in Smash
Brothers and today was announced a cloud
from final fantasy 7 would it be joining
the roster Nintendo showed off clouds
moves a limit bricks and a brand new
stage based on Final Fantasy 7 Mitka
this does also mean a cloud amiibo will
be on the way eventually the news
doesn't stop there though Nintendo have
also confirmed that twilight princess
will be arriving on we year
as previously rumored dubbed Twilight
Princess HD the game will have updated
graphics and is going to come packaged
with a newly announced wolf link amiibo
it will also be supporting the other
Legend of Zelda an EVO out now and
apparently progress save to your little
plastic people can carry over to the
game in a currently unspecified way
Twilight Princess HD is out most for up
next to you Nintendo also announced with
Square Enix's Dragon Quest seven and
eight remakes for the 3ds are coming to
the west the original Gameboy editions
of pokemon red blue and yellow are
coming to 3ds trifles heroes will get
free DLC Hyrule warriors will get a
female lead character as DLC and Star
Fox zero will be released on april 20
seconds finally Microsoft is premature
with their new xbox experience update
and they want you to be too the massive
update which arrives today is making big
changes to the user interface introduces
Windows 10 as the consoles underlying OS
and rings in backwards compatibility
support for xbox 360 games Microsoft's
Mike Nichols told GameSpot it's arguably
the most significant release we've ever
made to a console and that anybody's
ever made to a console the update is
intended to primarily improve speed and
intuitive mess as niggles claims that at
times the current dashboard has not been
a crowd-pleaser Nichols has said that in
some cases you will see a response time
that is 10 times faster than it was
previously another priority for
Microsoft has been making the activity
feed more discoverable and ensuring that
the things you use the console for most
are readily accessible and
load the updates will be around 1.1 k
let me know down in the comments what
you cared about today and what you
thought of today's stories hedgie game
slots and more Nintendo Direct articles
and our game of the month october that
is everything i have for you today but
do Pelt by same time tomorrow well have
my top five stories of all gaming week I
will get you then